Daniel gust only started work at
steelmakers that's Keita
in northern Germany one year ago he's in
charge of quality control but he's
already wondering if his job is safe in
recent years the steelworks has barely
been turning a profit even though it's
operating at full capacity competition
from China is pushing down prices right
now China is flooding the market with
cheap steel we wouldn't be able to
produce a single slab at those prices
these coils of steel will be turned into
cars or washing machines but the same
bought from Chinese companies cost 40
percent less than they do at sites Gaeta
the German company also feels
disadvantaged because unlike its Asian
competitors it has to abide by costly
environmental standards almost all the
steel workers are unionized the works
council is calling for better protection
of the EU market against steel imports
from China if your price is achieved
you'll sell your goods on the market
that's what has to be stopped so my
colleagues are afraid of understandably
they fear our company might have to
close down that's what we're all talking
about this can be also victims Uncle
Dean the steel workers don't want to end
up victims of globalization from the
factory floor to the executive floor the
company is determined to halt imports of
cheap steel
if you stay in the CFU someone inside we
manufacture for let's say 500 euros and
they sell it for 300 business can't
withstand that in the long run make
sense for the EU to regulators sites
Gaeta is a commercial company listed on
the stock exchange I'd to make a profit
operating on the free market the volume
of steel produced and its price are
determined by supply and demand
so let's get our management
argues that China is not a free market
its economy is planned and the country
produces too much steel not million
tonnes over capacity of about 400
million tons in the steel industry
that's double the amount we produce in
Europe this excess is exported to world
markets China is exporting its
structural problems which result from
processes that are not driven by market
forces Germany once had a powerful and
successful steel industry it has long
been in decline now accounts for just 2
to 3 percent of GDP the industry wants
to see tariffs on Chinese steel for six
months but economists warn that China
might respond by imposing tariffs on
imports of German machine parts
Stefan Thompson says open markets are
better of course this smacks of
protectionism but you have to see it in
context any compensating measures or
tariffs should only be temporary at
least at first
I think negotiations would be the way to
go the Chinese steel industry and
government know there is over capacity
and know they need to restructure the
steel industry
but in Silas Gita Daniel gassed and his
colleagues are losing patience cutbacks
in production and staff are now the norm
1,500 workers have already lost their
jobs the mood at the company is pretty
grim staff wonder if sides katha can
ride out the flood of cheap steel from
Asia moment on bizarre it is alarming
for me personally I'm relatively young
and highly skilled so I'm not in the
most immediate danger
Aladin I met four others at the company
especially older colleagues I've been
here for a long time
the situation is much more precarious
whatever the advantages of competition
on the marketplace many steel workers
here see globalization as jeopardizing
their jobs they're not going to give
them up without a fight
you